welcome to session four of this new
series understanding anger 2.0 this is
sort of a reprise of a talk series that
I did years and years and years ago in
person at the Kingston Public Library
hosted on Saturdays like it is in the
present but this time we're doing things
virtually and this series is going to be
looking at anger as depicted or
described or even
examined in in Greater depth in a number
of different authors and and works from
Antiquity all the way up to well we'll
see how far we get maybe into the early
modern maybe even into the late modern
period uh because of this online format
we can do this as long as we like and
the text that I picked out for today is
The Iliad and there's some good reasons
why I wanted to address that early on
and the first is that it is a work that
is not just involving and describing and
depicting anger it is a work that is
centered around anger or wrath or
however you want to talk about it the
very very first line and I'll be using
the Robert fagel's translation for this
it begins with an invocation to the
muses to sing of the Wrath or the rage
the Menace uh Achilles and so it takes
as its starting point for the story when
the two namely Achilles and Agamemnon
first clashed Agamemnon Lord of manner
commander of men and Godlike or
brilliant Achilles and both of them get
angry and their anger is going to have
Monumental uh consequences for the
achaeans or Greeks who are masked at
Troy in the ninth year of the war
they're actually really the tenth year
of the war they've been there nine years
and there's going to be all sorts of
other interests staying depictions of
anger
and we could think about the Iliad I
mean sometimes people will try to make
an analogy between Homer's works and
hessian's works you know the Iliad The
Odyssey Works in days the theogony and
stuff like that and they'll call it the
Greek bible
not quite correct it's not as if they
were you know
constantly orienting themselves by these
Sacred Scriptures or something like that
they did they did do a lot of proof
texting if uh Plato is to be trusted
people would bring up uh those but
they'd also bring up lines from other
poets simonides and people like that but
the Iliad and the Odyssey and then you
know next month we're going to be
looking at Hessian uh works and days
they had massive cultural impact on the
ancient Greeks and so we do see them uh
you know these works the
Odyssey the characters in them the
speeches getting addressed by other
people who are interested in the issue
of anger and so I think it's it's really
worth digging into it to see not sort of
lessons because there aren't lessons
being taught as such about anger but we
could say observations how it's being
depicted how it's being described when
anger is arising and this can be very
useful for us as we move forward and you
know this is our first foray into Greek
poetry
um I I think a lot of people know that
the Odyssey The Iliad are actually
written in uh you know a rhyme scheme
not uh end rhyme but rather meter and
this was uh you know considered very
important for the ancient Greeks
um it was an art form and we're talking
about epic poetry here we're going to be
looking at you know later on down the
line some what is called lyric poetry
and of course the um tragedies are
another type of poetry as well and you
know one of the things that you can say
about the poets if you haven't been
totally turned off from them by Plato
and his criticisms of his fellow poets
because he was a poet originally
um is that the poets provide us with
some useful Reflections on anger that
are hard one and thought out that
provide us with uh starting points for
thinking about this difficult emotion
particularly within the context of
conflict and and warfare so
that's all quite important to think
about and uh you know a few General
remarks that we could we could say
um you know the Iliad is set back in the
heroic or Bronze Age they actually use
the word uh hero in there at a number of
points in the Greek but there's not a
lot of idealizing going on oftentimes
when we think about the good old days
and the you know great warriors and
stuff like that you know for example
American history tends to get a lot of
white washing and you know George
Washington was this really wonderful guy
he actually wasn't he wasn't a great guy
uh he was okay at holding an army
together he lost most of his battles
um you know the whole thing about the
cherry tree and I shall never tell a lie
we know that's complete confabulation
you know the Homer is not like saying
with the ancient Greek Heroes oh look at
wonderful Achilles what a great guy he
is you know are so rational so so
willing to sacrifice one for the team no
I mean these people are being depicted
as in some cases real jerks and there
isn't a single like good guy in the
whole story they've all got flaws
um so that's that's kind of cool to
think about and you know this is a time
in which the gods are also involved in
human Affairs pretty closely we see the
gods actually getting into conflict with
with each other over this Trojan War the
war between the massed Greece Grecian or
Acadian host uh with all of these great
uh uh you know leaders of their own
little principalities massed against the
Trojans who have called upon their own
allies before and are now hemmed in in
their City uh two different you know uh
groups the the Trojans and their City
the Greeks by the ships in their camps
and it is a warrior culture that we're
looking at
so we should expect that anger is going
to be a really central part of what is
going on we're going to see later on
Agamemnon himself getting angry as he
goes up and down the ranks of those
fighting if he sees a man falling out
getting uh upset with them so anger and
courage contentiousness battle Revenge
reprisal these are all key things that
are motivating these people here on the
planes in front of Troy and so
anger is going to play a massive role
within the Iliad and we're going to look
at it book by book by book and take some
pauses here and there for mulling over
or you know asking questions or
dialoguing about what actually happens
in
um these these great you know stories
that are being told so you know first
off anger has a role in in Ancient
Warfare
um it's it helps people to get riled up
and be ready to Brave the danger of
fighting hand to hand it can motivate
people to take
necessary but dangerous action to wade
into the battle with their Spears and
swords and other armaments
um
anger you know is also
aroused as we're going to see at the
very beginning when somebody has a sense
of being treated as less than they
deserve being as we say
Dishonored a term that is gonna come up
quite a lot within the Iliad
particularly as Achilles views himself I
think quite rightly as being Dishonored
by Agamemnon the the Great War leader
and you know it also arises in the
course of disagreements about what
really matters or how to understand
things when people disagree with each
other we saw this when we discussed
Plato in uh the very uh second session
of this this uh series and then you know
once anger is aroused we see it looking
for satisfaction we see it
um like a a wound that can be poked and
prodded and riled back up you know we're
going to see Achilles for example
suggesting that Priam at the very end of
the book don't you get me angry again
you know and worrying about uh all these
things that are going to happen if they
do get angry
um anger also it very interestingly
provokes other emotional responses in
other people so we see Achilles anger
for example making other people feel
fear or dread
or sometimes we see characters
expressing awe or amazement or sorrow or
suffering or in many cases anger in
return I get angry at you you get angry
at me right
so um
we also have you know a world that's
murky and messy as I mentioned there are
no
white hat Good Guys in this right and
there aren't any complete villains
either it's a world in which there's
some right on everybody's side and it
can't all be reconciled together which
you might say is uh making it a tragic
piece even though it's not considered
Greek tragedy and so anger and revenge
is going to get involved in this and one
of the key attentions that we we have
that we're going to see worked out in
this uh then I'll address this this
comment
um
all the Greeks are under the rule of one
anox one war leader Agamemnon right the
ruler of men the king
um but at the same time they're also
free and so you know each of them freely
decides what they're going to do of
course motivated by concerns of honor
and glory and winning you know prizes so
perhaps oriented by wealth as well uh
you know a desire for social status so
on the one hand they're under orders on
the other hand they are free people who
can decide for themselves and how is
this all going to work out and how do
you apportion Goods like honor this is a
key question there so Mark has a comment
uh to me the appeal of Achilles story is
his being an exemplary tragic here okay
so coming back to this notion of tragedy
his glory is due to his martial
Excellence his Arete but his heel his
Achilles heel is anger now that's very
interesting we'll come back to that in a
moment courage and skill that is
overshadowed at times by an anger
associated with pride the vice the hero
risks even though we aren't Greek
warriors there are aspects in our lives
where we grapple with similar tension
between our virtue and weakness okay
that's those are some some good
observations and
we use this term Achilles heel to mean
like a person who otherwise is quite
resilient and strong the vulnerable
point at which they can be attacked and
perhaps even brought down you know if
you think about biblical Heroes Samson
and his hair right uh if you think about
David uh David and his lust right and in
the case of Achilles
yes it's it's
um it's his pride and his anger he is
not willing to be treated in the way
that Agamemnon is treating him so this
is a good place to jump in and look at
the central conflict that sets up
everything else at the start and we're
going to see anger is going to arise on
the part of multiple people and anger is
going to provoke other anger
so as I mentioned We Begin by hearing uh
Maine Aida Thea right rage got a sing of
the Rage of peleus's son Achilles
murderous doomed that caused the akians
countless losses hurling down to the
house of death so many sturdy Souls
Achilles by his withdrawal from Battle
is going to put the Greeks at a
disadvantage and then it goes on and
says begin Muse when the two first
broken clashed what God drove them to
fight with such a fury and the words
that are being used there are not so
much anger words but rather conflict
words we have uh eres right in the
dative eridi and as a noun
eresante they got into Strife with each
other they clashed they became enemies
to each other they came came into
conflict why did this happen well
because
Agamemnon has ticked off the god the god
Apollo
and we're going to see this term over
and over again coming up
um
so the you know this is a bit of a
digression but the anger vocabulary that
we're going to see in Homer's Iliad
isn't really using the main term that
later Greek writers will use for anger
right and it's not even using the word
thumos quite as much something that we
explored in great detail in Plato in our
previous session number three instead
it's going to be holos and uh Menace and
a few other terms now hold those can
mean bile like what it is that the liver
produces the liver and black bile melon
Halos were viewed as being a location or
Source or or you could say the bodily
component of the emotion of anger so
we're going to see this term coming up
over and over again and we see that the
God is angered at Agamemnon
right and imposes a disease which Apollo
could do very easily because he's the
Lord of diseases onto the army
the Greek army because of the treatment
of his priest whose daughter has been
taken as a prize and so you know there's
this terrible plague going on and you
know the the achaeans are like Agamemnon
you gotta give her back you've got to
make things right between the God and us
and Agamemnon says I'm not giving her
back so the priest prays and after you
know and the priest is praying the
priest is himself angered and he's
praying to the God and so the god
imposes this uh terrible pestilence and
on the 10th day Achilles calls the Army
to to muster into a group right and
speaks to Agamemnon and suggests that
they consult a prophet so they do that
and the prophet caucus
explains Apollo's anger and now the word
here is Menace uh and you know the the
the term that was used originally for
Achilles Achilles's rage so he's
explaining Achilles uh Apollo's rage at
the Greeks but caucus first asks
Achilles to protect him because he knows
that he's going to anger Agamemnon who
is going to keep or literally digest the
burning in his chest uh uh hold on again
and Carter Pepsi we get Pepsis for you
know as digestion later on and so it's
gonna be like a heartburn you know and
Agamemnon might take it out on him
so then you know after Achilles gives
some assurances calcus says well
Agamemnon has Dishonored The Gods priest
and the word that's actually used there
atimace meaning timay is honor and Oz
taking away so he's taken away the honor
of the priest and thereby the honor of
the god Apollo and this is why he's
suffering now Agamemnon himself Rises
he's upset or grieving or Furious
depending on how you want to translate
it
umenos is the the term there and it says
his dark heart filled to the brim
blazing with anger uh and once again we
see Menace as the term there
right so his his chest his heart has
been filled with great anger and he says
that he'll give the girl back
but now he demands a prize of value to
himself so he'll accept being told that
he has to do something but he wants to
sort of like push the damage off onto
somebody else and he accuses Achilles of
trying to cheat him but interestingly
here at this point he's not just
singling out Achilles he's sort of
spreading it onto the great commanders
he says he'll take a prize from Achilles
or from Ajax or Odysseus now what's
going on there
these are recognized as being the
greatest of the Greek Fighters as a
matter of fact there's another one
diameters that uh is going to like even
be able to attack Gods later on
um who Agamemnon is going to say he's
not really as great a warrior as these
other people and so he says I'm going to
take their prize and let that man choke
with anger and the term there is
so we have this holos again there right
and it's being sort of like reinforced
let that man be just filled with anger
Achilles then reminds Agamemnon of
something pretty important so this goes
back to the attention that we were
talking about earlier
the Trojans didn't do any wrong to
Achilles and so many others could say
this as well they are following
Agamemnon and Agamemnon doesn't Dole out
the prizes equally and achilles actually
says you know what if you're going to
act this way I might leave town I'm
going to tell my guys get back on their
ships and screw you you're on your own
jackass it doesn't quite say it like
that and Agamemnon uh you know you can
see he's angered right because what is
the next thing he says he's like yeah
fine go if you want to go even if you're
a great warrior you don't matter to me
you're nothing to me nor does your anger
or Grudge your Cote antos being being
upset and he says I'll take your prize
Brisas so that you can learn how much
greater I am than you so what do we see
here we see social status once again and
Agamemnon is going to inflict a penalty
on Achilles because Agamemnon himself is
angered and he's going to take revenge
no longer against the God but against
the person who has brought matters to a
head so this is clearly misdirected
anger and this anger is Achilles so this
is where we get the Rage of Achilles
that was referenced at the beginning and
what we find is he's in a crisis
a horse
and here's the line the heart in his
rugged chest was pounding torn so he's
got two different directions he could go
should he draw the long sword slung at
his hip thrust through the ranks and
kill Agamemnon now which is certainly a
possibility for Achilles because he is
the greatest arguably uh and
demonstrably later on of all of the
Greek warriors I mean we could say maybe
Ajax as his rival but Ajax can't beat
Hector and achilles can't right so if he
wanted to go after Agamemnon he could
have done that or should he check his
rage and beat his Fury down so here we
have two different anger words kolos and
thumon being used right
um and what Achilles does is he begins
to draw his blade and now we get one of
the first Divine interventions I suppose
you could say it's the second divine
intervention because Apollo has already
intervened on the part of his priest
right and of course we have the prophet
kalkus who is Consulting things as well
but what we have here is Athena is going
to show up
Hera and Athena both of them love
Achilles and Athena commands Achilles
she says I came down from the skies to
check your rage your thumos if you will
only yield and he does he listens to the
the god
he tells Agamemnon then you know you
send other man and men into battle you
don't risk your own life and I'm not
going to fight for you anymore and then
we see Nestor who is going to be an
important character at several points
and remember that Nestor will show up in
the Odyssey as well not as Nestor but as
Athena disguised as Nestor and Nestor is
an old man who's very smart and he
pleads with both of these great leaders
uh telling Agamemnon to let his anger go
against Achilles because Achilles is a
ball work or wall against their foes and
then Agamemnon sends the man to take
Brisas from Achilles camp and this is
where it the the
action you could say ends so the very
first
um scene in The Iliad is of Agamemnon
and achilles clashing the goddess
interfere intervening and uh everything
being set up Achilles now will take
himself out of action and the Greeks for
a while are going to be on their own now
here's a good comment bile indigestion
choking
I enjoy the visceral imagery of anger
yeah and and so this is a little bit of
a side note as well one of the things
that we see over and over and over again
throughout the Iliad
and this may indeed lead to Plato's
location of thumos later on in in the
chest
um or the thorax as they they called it
is that we'll see the anger vocabulary
using the terms uh Menace or holos or
occasionally thumos and then it'll be
you know
um
an anatomical and we could say
psychological language as well anger in
the chest but it's also you know
associated with this this notion of bile
of digestion of like nursing your anger
inside your guts so to speak so these
are this is yeah you're right visceral
imagery I mean visceral and more than
one sense right
so let's go on and uh we do have
something that's kind of an interesting
little comic interlude in book two and I
wanted to bring it up in part because
what we see here is
not anger although we could read it in
if we wanted to
and what we have here is this guy
theresites who is the ugliest uh a
deformed guy who utters abuse and
obscenities and baits the the various
you know great leaders he's the comic
relief right and interestingly in this
there isn't going to be any comic relief
uh the the only comic relief is Odysseus
actually when when their cities goes
after Agamemnon and is taunting him
Odysseus threatens to strip and beat him
and then takes agamemnon's scepter his
you know symbol of rulership and beats
him with the scepter and everybody's
laughing now no longer along with their
cities at the you know rulers and the
powerful uh Warriors They're laughing
adversities and they all think that he's
getting what he deserves and this is
sort of a bonding moment for them at the
expense of thirsties now what I think is
really quite extraordinary about this
you would expect to read some anger
language in this scene like Agamemnon
getting ticked off and saying take care
of this this guy right or if their satis
himself being angry or Odysseus being
angry we don't see any anger language
being used here what we do see is
punishment or perhaps you could say
retaliation and revenge but we don't see
any anger and you know later on we're
going to see that there's a lot of
discussions in literature about how
laughing or comedy
sometimes can lead to anger but
sometimes can help us to dispel anger so
you know I think that's probably enough
said about that
in book four
we get this incredible uh Association or
it's called the Council of the Gods
right and the gods have been taking
sides in the Trojan War not least
because you know as we learn later on
not in The Iliad but in the Odyssey
um the whole war was started in part
over the goddess of Discord eres a term
that we've already encountered
um having this golden apple and the the
goddesses you know it's to the fairest
Paris decides for Aphrodite Athena and
Hera are pissed off and uh you know they
they're like yeah we're gonna see some
sort of punishment here and then of
course the human Affairs taking Helen
the uh uh you know vow that all the
Greeks had made to Menelaus when he
married Helen that if anybody stole her
they'd all help out and Menelaus of
course is the brother to Agamemnon
um they sail to Troy and now the Gods
been you know engaging in the conflict
through human proxies for quite a long
time
and Athena and Hera are the ones who
most want the destruction of Troy
and what we see going on here in the
story is Zeus says something and if
Athena is silent but she's resentful at
at Zeus
um she is angry but she keeps her anger
you know checked Hera however the wife
of Zeus uh queen of the gods she cannot
contain her anger in her breast uh again
she has hollown and it's not contained
stathos within her chest and she
criticizes Zeus's plan for truce why
because he is meddling and undoing the
work that she has done the work is
killing Trojans and Zeus then gets angry
himself the Greek there is Meg okay
right another anger word and he
criticizes Hera's own insatiable anger
and suggests that she had better not
interfere with his Fury when he wants to
destroy a city and Hera raises the
stakes she says you know what you can
destroy my three favorite cities and I
won't resist let me destroy this city
though
uh what are her favorite cities Argos
and Sparta and maisonet
and so
um Zeus then sends Athena who's you know
looking for trouble down to break the
truce disguised as a Trojan and she
suggests that an Archer should shoot an
arrow at Menelaus and then the truce is
broken and the war resumes so the anger
that's felt on the part of the Gods
bleeds over into resumption of the
conflict and fury and anger on both
sides and what we see then we're going
to skip over a number of books is you
know all sorts of cool battles going on
you know some of which are concerned
with diomedes and we see Ajax doing
things but you know the war is not going
great
for the
um the Greeks the achaeans so we should
pause here for a minute we'll see if
there's any questions comments things to
take note of dig deeper into and then
we'll jump into looking at
um in the middle of the book
admitting his mistake but Achilles not
responding the way that he wants to so
uh here's a good point
God's getting angry no wonder Socrates
denounced them yeah and I mean there
were other
Greek thinkers
um you know the first person that comes
to mind is epicurus who's you know a
later generation of course but uh his
principal doctrines Begin by saying the
gods don't get angry it's not the coming
of them
um clearly you know Socrates seem to he
did introduce new Notions of the Gods
right
um which could have been Empire any
Plato certainly uh didn't think that the
gods should be depicted as getting angry
um and we have other we have other
philosophers and it's primarily
philosophers who are saying that's
that's modeling the gods after us the
gods are not as screwed up as us
for Homer clearly the gods are as
screwed up as us they're just much much
more powerful and Immortal right so this
is kind of an interesting
point right and and we could we could
pause on this a moment because we're
going to talk later on about the gods
getting angry again at each other
and
you know think about the what it's what
it's suggesting to you as a reader or as
a hearer of these uh these Tales
so there's it's kind of a pessimistic
viewpoint on anger
there's nothing like therapy of the Soul
there's nothing like
anger management other than just don't
let your anger get away with you or
let's not tick people off so we've got
approaches to anger in a very
rudimentary sense when it comes to
rational approaches to anger instead
they're almost either avoidance or
appeasement or we've got to let the
anger go where it's going to go Gods are
morally neutral like a force of nature
yeah I mean or you could say that
the line between good and bad runs
through the Gods
they're kind of mixtures of both I mean
they they will make moral arguments to
each other you shouldn't behave this way
or they have uh responses of moral
emotions like we said Zeus himself gets
angry at Hera over her anger and her
expression of anger so clearly he thinks
that it's not good for her or she's
somehow shaming him by by showing this
anger right
so yeah the gods are an interesting
topic let's go to book nine now so
what do we see here diameters is going
to oppose Agamemnon and uh says to spare
him his anger that that Agamemnon has
not shown courage and that uh if he
wants to leave he can but the Greeks
will stay and fight because Agamemnon
now is actually threatening to like take
off himself and Nestor speaks up once
again and says it's time for you to make
things right with Achilles and he tells
them that in your anger Agamemnon you
have Dishonored a great man namely
Achilles and then Agamemnon
interestingly because he is he is a real
anger driven jerk right
he admits that he was insane blinded
angered but now he's going to make
things right and the way that he's going
to do it is by promising and providing
gifts a as they call it a ransom for
friendship and he promises the uh you
know restoration of Brisas his prize to
him uh he also mentions that he hasn't
he hasn't slept with her and he says uh
what if Troy Falls I'll also give you
all sorts of really great War booty as
as well
and I'll do this if Achilles just ends
his anger uh met the lake Santi oloyo
you know once again holos this bile
expression so he sends an embassy and it
includes Nestor and it includes another
older man Phoenix and Ajax and Odysseus
and Patrol place and achilles uh welcome
them as guests to their camp and then uh
a killer or Odysseus is going to make
his argument
he says the Trojans are close to beating
us and they're gonna be up to our ships
pretty soon there's still time let your
heart devouring anger go and again they
use this term holos and he says
Agamemnon is going to give you all sorts
of gifts to make things right and you
can also gain Glory the greatest Glory
by killing Hector the hero of the
Trojans
and achilles responds to him and says
that he hates a person who says one
thing and hides another in his heart and
that Agamemnon and the Greeks are not
going to win him over he suffered years
for them and a war against people who
aren't his enemy and then the war leader
took his honor and his prize he'll even
now consider sailing back home so
Odysseus's appeal is clearly
unsuccessful Achilles is still angry and
then Phoenix says that Achilles is being
Mastered by his anger and he brings up a
case from his own backstory an incident
when he and his father were at odds in
anger and he considered killing his
father and a god checked his anger and
the kin kept him there feasting for I
think it was nine days and then he took
off and he continues and he says it's
wrong to have an iron ruthless heart
look at the guy Gods even they can be
appused if Agamemnon was still angry and
not offering gifts then it would be fine
for you Achilles to stay angry at him
but Agamemnon is making a good faith
effort to try to produce a
Reconciliation so you should do your
part Achilles and you know accept the
the the the
apology and the the prizes and rejoin us
and achilles says no
then Ajax suggests that they should
leave because they're unsuccessful and
he says Achilles is just Savage he
doesn't think of his companions the gods
notice that he's going to blame this on
the gods have planted cruel Relentless
Fury in his chest so again uh kakon to
thumod thumos anger right cocoon bad uh
evil and it's planted and stathacy in in
your your chest an Achilles then says
you know
when I recall how Agamemnon treated me
dishonoring me not just privately but in
front of all the Greeks my heart is
filled with anger and so they leave and
then they go and tell again that
Achilles is still full of anger and he
spurns him and his gifts and there's
nothing that Agamemnon can do now at
this point right and the Greeks are
fighting against the Trojans and as we
know what's going to happen is
um things are going to get particularly
desperate Patrol case who is uh
Achilles's best friend and probably
lover certainly looked at that way in
later literature puts on Achilles his
armor goes out and Hector strikes him
down
and
not only does he strike him down
um
he as we find out in book 18
they're fighting over his corpse they're
trying to get it back uh his his corpse
has been stripped of the armor Hector
now has not only taken his friend's life
but also Achilles own arms and achilles
falls into a deep grief
interestingly his his first response is
not that of anger let me go out there
and kill this son of a it's grief
grief for what he has lost and then he
gets to the point where he's like yeah
I'm gonna go and fight this guy
and then his mother
The Immortal nymph thetas warns him if
you kill Hector you're gonna die soon
after
an Achilles laments the strife and the
anger that brought him there and we get
this really really famous passage that
we're going to see people quoting
throughout Antiquity uh which brings up
anger sweeter than honey swarming in
people's chest blinding like smoke uh
host to polu glucion melitos right so
maliitos Mel is honey and uh glucion
means sweeter than Aristotle himself
will bring this up in his discussions of
anger and achilles is reflecting on how
did things get so screwed up how did
things get to this point well my anger
is part of that and it's interesting
because what we notice happening if we
if we're reading between the lines and
we're looking at the way
uh Homer has Achilles talking about
things
his anger is something that overcomes
him his anger is something that arises
it's also something that he can
stand back from and consider at a
distance
this is going to be coming up again
later on so maybe there's maybe there is
a lesson there for us to learn
Achilles then cleans and washes his
friend's body and Mourns him and have
faced us asked by thatus makes arms for
Achilles and we get this very famous
passage that we're going to skip over
where it describes the you know Shield
of Achilles in great detail uh Homer was
apparently very into that in the ancient
Greeks were as well but we're interested
in the workings of anger and so this is
going to lead to a Reconciliation in
Book 19 between Achilles and Agamemnon
so they are brought back in the same
place
and achilles tells Agamemnon
was it better for you and I to rage at
each other raked by anguish consumed by
Strife all for a young girl the prize
Brisas right
Achilles now has perspective so does
Agamemnon and
um you know what what do we see here
there's a recognition that their
conflict wasn't really necessary and it
was over the wrong sorts of things and
achilles tells us he will call a halt to
his anger grieving grieving for
patroclus he will bring an end to the
anger in his breast thumon any states
the sea and he also uses In this passage
the words hold on and Main in so we have
all the anger vocabulary located in
Achilles chest he's going to bring a
halt to it then Agamemnon says something
there's a lot of blaming on you know
things on the gods Agamemnon blames
things uh on the Gods in this case
namely ruin or ate and he says that this
God ate compelled him to take Achilles's
prize and then we get an interesting
exchange
Odysseus you know Achilles is like all
right let's go fight now and and
Odysseus is like well no no let's have a
little meal let's have a feast right
let's commemorate this and also we
shouldn't fight on an empty stomach you
know we should uh uh get get get
ourselves uh back in gear
Agamemnon for his part wants to give
gifts to Achilles he's he's trying to
reconcile again but Achilles wants to go
out and fight and he says all of that
feasting and stuff that can wait until A
Lull in the battle when I don't have
Fury in my chest or in my heart and
again he uses the term Menace uh and uh
stethosy and he says that his taste is
for Slaughter and blood and groans of
men so what are we seeing here
Achilles
is motivated now still by anger but the
anger has been redirected at the Trojans
away from uh Agamemnon and the Greeks
who are going along with agamemnon's
mistreating of him that is now dealt
with and now he's full of anger full of
Fury to go after the Trojans and
specifically Hector their greatest hero
so here's an interesting remark you
mentioned laughter earlier maybe
Achilles could have done more damage to
Agamemnon with a cutting wit than his
rage
yeah and if if Achilles had been say
Odysseus
right uh Odysseus is good at that sort
of thing
um not all the Greek heroes are you know
we you get the idea that Achilles is
much quicker with his sword and his
spear than he is with his wits and
that's definitely the case for uh the
greater Ajax too who becomes you know a
great rival to Odysseus
um Odysseus is smarter than than the
rest of them and a great fighter too but
he's he's more a person of thought
Odysseus is by the way sort of a you
know inter let's call him uh somebody in
between
the great you know uh we call you know
in in role-playing games they call the
fighters tanks right tanks like Ajax and
achilles and the great thinker types
like Nestor or Phoenix
Odysseus has got it got it both but you
know there's a whole other story that
where he's the main uh character that
we'll talk about maybe down the line
when we reprise Homer
but yeah
um
a cutting remark
could have maybe dealt with things but
they don't need to make any remarks like
that at this point because they the
achaeans are reconciled with each other
and
um Achilles is ready to go out and fight
and kill and that is indeed what he does
and so we see in book 21 he
um is filling up the river xanthos with
blood and
um
so book 20 ended with this brutal
Relentless assault of Achilles on the
Trojans nobody can stand up to him he's
killing guys left and right and then we
get this really interesting scene
um
lycone begs for his life he says you
know killing me it's not really going to
do anything and achilles says you know
before patroclus's death I might have
granted you Mercy but I'm not gonna do
it now get ready to die death waits for
all of us I'm gonna die you're gonna die
you're just gonna die sooner at my hand
and he starts killing Trojans and
there's all these depictions about how
he's doing it and it's the blood is
flowing into the river
and the river is going to get angry
itself pulled the most hola Santo uh
querothy Malone or resemendum
right the river is getting angry at uh
Achilles for making things too messy and
it takes a human shape and it says it's
going to stop Achilles uh it tells them
you know you're greater than any man on
Earth but you're also greater in Outrage
in hubris
and so the two of them fight and and one
ends up happening as Achilles jumps into
the river and the river is fighting him
with all of its resources a Whirlpool
that's sucking him down Poseidon and
Athena and Hera all get involved and
Harris saves Achilles from the
whirlpools otherwise the river would
have presumably have killed him
um have faced us actually uses fire
against the river so the gods now are
fighting on the side of Achilles or at
least some of them right because what
then ends up happening
Total War God against God Ares fighting
against Athena Athena beats Aries two
gods of War right one the the maid
representing strategy the other
bloodthirsty uh son of Hera fighting
against each other
Aphrodite actually uh has to take Aries
away after he loses Poseidon and Apollo
fight each other
Hera goes after Artemis so we have all
of these Divine forces now lined up
against each other it's no longer just
Trojan versus uh akaian with the gods
you know advising them or helping them
out every once in a while the gods
themselves are fighting each other and
then we get to book uh 22 and we have
this you know classic scene between the
two greatest heroes on the battlefield
Achilles and Hector Hector knows he's
going to die and he begs Achilles one
thing he doesn't say spare my life
he asks for proper funeral rights once
again we see Achilles saying
you know before patroclus before you
screwed with the guy that I I care about
I would have uh been merciful to you but
he says to him something really dramatic
would to God my rage my theory would now
drive me to hack your flesh away and eat
you raw his his Rage Against the killer
of his friend is so great that he's
threatening cannibalism
he is threatening not just to dishonor
the corpse not to give it proper funeral
rights but to himself as an agent to uh
his that his rage his Fury would allow
him to cut off parts of the person's
body living her dead and consume them
so this is uh this is pretty
you know out of control anger there and
he kills Hector
and then in order to perhaps vent his
rage he allows the other Greeks to come
through and stab Hector's body uh you
know essentially just filling it with
holes and then he strips the corpse as
Hector did to his his friend patroclus
but he binds it to the Chariot that he's
riding and he drives around
the city
um essentially defiling the corpse right
showing that he's going to destroy
Hector not just uh in battle not just
with a blow but to ruin his his body so
and this is what anger often you know
drives people to do to take uh brutal
uh desperate revenge against those who
they view as having violated norms and
then we get to the Dem you know sort of
the ending of all of this we see that
Achilles has
um Dishonored The Corpse
cream who is lost now all of uh his his
Great sons
um is going to try to get the body back
um you know his life has essentially
been been ruined and so Priam talks
first with Hermes who is disguised as
one of Achilles's warriors uh one of his
mirmidons and they tell him that there's
been something quite
extraordinary happening we could call it
a miracle if we wanted
um Hector's corpse is still lying by the
ships but it hasn't been scavenged by
birds or dogs and it's not rotting and
so this gives Priam I won't say hope but
at least heart to go and ask or rather
beg for his son's body back and Priam
goes and meets with Achilles and He
suggests his argumentative uh tactic
here is that he remember his own father
and pity Priam who has lost so much in
the process
and here we get one of the scenes that
so many people uh will bring to mind as
being something absolutely of central
importance to
The Iliad
both of them grieve they grieve together
um Priam is grieving for his son Hector
killed by Achilles
Achilles is grieving for his father who
is like Priam and he's grieving for
patroclus killed by Hector and they
grieve together
and Prime then once again asks for his
son and achilles says something really
extraordinary here especially in
relation to his anger remember that I
said that Achilles at a certain point
was able to sort of stand back from his
anger realizing that it could control
him if he allowed it to
him so Achilles tells pram in response
to being asked for the body do not tempt
my wrath don't reawaken it
but he says also I made up my mind to
give you your son's body back
so don't ask me for what I've already
decided upon
and achilles has the body then bathed
and anointed and we get another really
extraordinary Insight here in book 24.
Achilles is himself worried that Priam
is going to get angered at seeing his
son's defiled body now what does he have
to fear from prying nothing Priam is an
old man
Priam can't hurt him
Achilles is worried that he is going to
in response to priam's anger
himself get angered his anger will arise
again and that he will then hurt Priam
as a result so we see it you know some
some real uh reflective Insight on the
part of Achilles he understands that
anger could take control of him and he
wants to avoid that with a former enemy
Achilles then picks up Hector himself
and he places him on the funeral buyer
and then he says one other thing and
this is the last thing that we have to
say about anger coming from all of these
books
he says to his friend patroclus who is
now dead and presumably in the
Underworld he says feel no anger at me
patroclus that he's been given a ransom
for the loss of patroclus and he's going
to give patroclus his share of that
Ransom presumably through sacrifice
through appeasing the dead and what do
we have here we have a landscape that
has been dominated by anger and its
effects for so long the devastation
brought about by it you know in terms of
so many people killed mutilated
terrorized but also the damage that has
been done within to these Warriors and
we have an overcoming or at least a
cessation of this terrible force of
anger on the part of those who are still
alive and now to some degree at least
reconciled with each other and so that
is The Iliad and the great theme of
anger within it we see that there's a
number of different points and anybody
can get angry
uh some more than others Achilles can
get very angry Agamemnon can get very
angry uh many other even rivers and gods
and people like that
presumably uh Odysseus is a little bit
better at holding on to his anger but
even he will you know get ticked off
from time to time as well
so you know good thing to think about
here are there lessons being taught
through the way this story is told
um I would say yes but it's things that
you have to reflect upon there's nothing
here about like how to
manage your anger with techniques or
stuff like that or theoretical anger is
working this way or that way as we'll
see in later philosophers
but I think that the examples the
negative examples being provided
are probably very helpful
you know thinking about why people get
angry dishonor things being taken from
them
um being
having having somebody killing people in
your waters on the part of the river
right uh somebody basically muddying you
up
um how to get some distance from or
perspective upon your anger when you
should reconcile and when you shouldn't
these are all I think valuable if not
lessons perhaps topics so
that is all that I had lined up by way
of lecture
uh oh here's an interesting question
Greg you're a veteran did your did The
Iliad impact your understanding of being
a soldier anger seems like something
you'd want to learn to control a serving
in the military
yeah so that's a great topic right
um and this is where a lot of
misunderstandings arise on the part of
um people who
idealize or idolize the military
um you don't want angry people in battle
you want people who can actually keep a
cool head and this is something that
ancient philosophers noted Aristotle
talks about this
um he also or uh Seneca talks about this
Plutarch talks about this all the people
that are like attentive to anger they're
like you know it's not a great idea to
go into battle super angry it might give
you some temporary
energy or motivation or daring but it it
leads you into making dumb decisions
right
in the in the modern Battlefield
where so much is being done at a
distance it's it's not really helpful to
get angry or even to just get irritated
I mean there's so many things that could
irritate you in the modern Battlefield
being under Fire uh your friends dying
crappy food bad conditions stupid
officers who don't know what they're
doing right we could go on and on and on
and on but anger doesn't work as a
particularly good motivating force and
it tends to produce a lack of cohesion
among the people that you're supposed to
be working with
um now if if your Battlefield is all
hand-to-hand combat maybe you know like
in the Greek times uh well in the heroic
age maybe there's a role for it but we
notice already that with people like for
example uh Seneca point out that you
know the the the Nations that allow
anger through most whatever we want to
call it to dominate they actually are
scary but crappy Fighters because they
can't fight in formation properly right
so like they can't do a phalix they
can't do a uh Roman manipul or whatever
whatever else it's going to be and
they're scary at the start but they're
they break down pretty quickly
so that that's a good that's a good
question any other uh questions comments
uh things that people want to bring up
I will say that
um it was very enjoyable rereading The
Iliad four
you know preparing for this this
discussion because uh
such a great work of literature such
great characterization of the people
involved and you know there's they're
being presented heroically but as I
pointed out they're not being idealized
they're not being turned into
stock figures you know Achilles really
is struggling
Agamemnon is kind of a jerk oblivious to
um what he's doing and he's sometimes a
good leader and a lot of times not a
good leader and he has to be counseled
by the other people and there is this
tension of well we're under orders but
we're also free people and and you know
not only does Achilles suggest that he
might pull up and leave even an
Agamemnon as I pointed out is like yeah
you know been here a long time you guys
are a bunch of jerks maybe I'll take off
right and diameters has to say to him
yeah go ahead you know uh you're you're
a crappy leader anyway
uh here's a good good one I thought the
Troy movie was fun would a more faithful
adaptation of The Iliad as the short
Series be something that interests you
yeah a faithful adaptation
um
I mean this is something that we could
say about
so many bits of literature even down to
you know 20th century speculative
fiction stuff
if you if you've formed a very strong
attachment
to the original text then it kind of
bothers you oftentimes to see them being
um
butchered being done badly right and you
can even say there's a bit of anger in
us that that sometimes Rises on on
behalf of the author on behalf of the
work
um now you know sometimes this can be
kind of silly I remember as a kid
um having to be told because I I went
and saw Indiana Jones in the Temple of
Doom with uh my mother and sister and
some family friends and coming out of
the theater and people saying how did
you like it and I was like that was
terrible the thuggies weren't remotely
like that you know and then they they
very quickly like rolled their eyes and
they're like ah Greg's on his
again you know
um
can't you just watch a movie you know
now that in that case getting upset
about uh a bad caricature of a religious
act in India
probably over the line right
um seeing crappy adaptations where they
really really missed the mark of classic
or contemporary great literature
I don't know maybe maybe if if not anger
uh maybe we should feel something about
that like a sense of indignation why
didn't they do this better you know and
usually the answer is something simple
like well they didn't think the audience
would be able to follow it or they
thought a love interest was needed or we
had to stick to the Hollywood formula or
something along those lines
um
but yeah short a short faithful
adaptation of The Iliad would be really
cool uh one that you know spent enough
time on the different Heroes and
actually found ways to depict the Gods
in conflict with each other
um in imaginative ways that would be
that would be pretty awesome I think you
know
um you want it so this goes back to
something
this is a bit of a side note
um one of the things that Aristotle
points out in his PO in his uh Poetics
because he's talking about tragedy is
that
um there's he identifies six elements of
it and the three that are particularly
important for poetry are
um plot muthos the story what happens
you know what's going on right and a lot
of times adaptations are okay at that
although they simplify the plots
considerably and then character ethos
right and this is how the people display
their character their virtues and vices
through their choices their words their
actions their thoughts right and that is
where a lot of times the typical
American Productions of things start to
fail you know they present Achilles as a
different kind of guy than he is they
present Agamemnon is a different kind of
guy than he is right
um
they want to simplify the characters
they want to turn things into you know
if not all white and black hats at least
the kinds of anti-heroes that we we
already know about and then we have
another really really important
Dimension that Aristotle can't stress
enough thought the annoya the people in
the story
say things that Express their frame of
mind they make arguments they make
appeals they explain what they're doing
and a lot of times in uh Hollywood stuff
this is done through like info dumps
um or there'll be like a setup for a
motivation they'll talk about some you
know traumatic event that happened that
they're trying to work their way through
but
that's not all that Hollywood people
think that's what makes things relatable
I think that actually hearing people say
interesting things is more relatable
even if we're distanced from them by
culture and time and you know social
class and pick whatever else you want I
think letting Achilles actually speak
for himself in a proper way would be
quite compelling hearing what the guy
thinks and has to say you know and the
same thing with Hector and the same
thing with Odysseus and the same thing
with Ajax and
going on and on and on so that's a bit
of a digression but great question so
any other questions comments as we wrap
this up
uh again I'll say that I really enjoyed
I don't know how many times I've read
The Iliad over the course of my life but
it's one of those texts that you can
tell it's a classic because it just
keeps getting better each time that you
read it you know
um
looking forward to going back to the
Odyssey which I I like better than the
Iliad because uh
you know I'm uh I'm a big fan of
Odysseus all right here's one from Mark
any good heavy metal songs about the
Ilia do you know of no but that's a I'm
sure there's plenty out there you know
um I really only know
um classic heavy metal well and I and
there's all sorts of obscure bands that
I don't know of that you can find out
there
some of whom probably have written about
produce songs that have to do with at
least something from The Iliad
so I'm sure there's stuff out there I'm
just not a great one for for uh doing it
oh that's here's an interesting
follow-up I'm surprised Iron Maiden
hasn't done a song on it yeah you're
right if there is any High stature
classic metal band that love to do
historically focused stuff particularly
about war
it would be Iron Maiden right I mean if
it was sacks and it would be about modes
of transportation like Wheels of Steel
or things like 747s
um
you know Judas Priest doesn't really do
a lot of that sort of stuff neither does
Motorhead but Iron Maiden uh yeah they
love doing those historically founded
things uh if they're gonna do Alexander
the Great why not do a song about
Achilles
um Kelly sonaga memnon you know a
standing toe-to-toe one of them about to
strike the other down and Athena showing
up that's like tailor-made for an Iron
Maiden song so that might actually be a
good place to bring this to a close uh
I'm kind of a interesting high note so
thanks for all the great comments uh
we'll be resuming next month talking
about Hessian and uh Works in days and
perhaps getting into the theogony as
well and then after that we're going to
go back to philosophers again which will
be quite fun
um so that is it for this one